when did I realize I was an entrepreneur
so I got a question that came in on
Twitter love you guys from Crawford &
Wilcox wrote in to say when did you
first realize you were an entrepreneur
that's a great question i think i've
been i've had entrepreneurial tendencies
my whole life one of my earliest
memories was when I was five years old
and I encouraged my three-year-old
little sister to create drawings with me
paintings with me that we then went door
to door and started selling to our
neighbors for five or ten cents and so I
made my first you know nickel from my
neighbor selling them a piece of art
that I made and she probably just felt
sorry for me or saw this cute little kid
and wanted to support the cause and I
guess a nickel or dime is not much money
through my childhood I was always
involved in various entrepreneurial
ventures so I sold lemonade ice old
baseball cards I created garage sales I
remember one time trying to turn raisins
into grapes on a hot summer day and was
going to hit this plan to sell these
grapes not realizing that it was the
opposite where you turn grapes in the
radar grapes and the reasons anyway you
know that being said throughout my my
early life I thought I was going to have
a job you know one of the one of the
greatest experience I had was with
Junior Achievement which was a program
that's in elementary and high schools
and I remember when I was a great nine
they taught us the basis of running a
company through this coupled a course
called business basics where you launch
the pen company yourself and then they
have a program called company program
where you launch a company in school
after hours and you have advisors and
mentors who come from companies to help
you actually launch your own product and
I started off just as a as an employee
at that company and then the next year
became vice president of production and
the next year became the president of
the company and so grew through that and
I enjoyed the challenge enjoyed the
entrepreneurial spirit but still when I
graduated high school when they asked
you in your yearbook you know what do
you want to be when you you know in 10
years what do you see yourself I said I
would be a VP at some invest
bang that was still my goal I guess
getting out of high school and it
changed in university I had an
opportunity to partner up with two
people who are at my university and they
had started a software company biotech
software they needed help getting it off
the ground they had a great piece of
software but needed help promoting it
marketing it I didn't know anything
about software I didn't run over biotech
and I i joined in to help them just as a
fun thing to do new experience see what
happens and it got to the point where
you guys have heard this story probably
watched my channel for a whiles make it
300 bucks a month you know barely
surviving with this company and I had
opportunities to go work with with two
companies who were in investment banking
in strategic consulting things that I
would have loved to do like that was my
that was what I thought I wanted to do
with my life and they were courting me
and they flew mid in New York and put me
up in nice hotels and you know why
didn't dine me offering 80 $100,000
starting salary traveling around the
world doing lots of fun cool things that
jobs that that my friends were were
killing for jobs that even you know two
years ago would have been wow I can't
believe I got this opportunity it's so
great and I had to decide between taking
these you know high-paying dream job of
a lifetime and continuing with the
business that I had joined as an owner I
make it 300 bucks a month and rationally
it makes sense that go for the job right
like everything leads you towards a job
it's it's stable that secure it's tons
of money it's what I always wanted it's
travel it's it's like the dream
opportunity and yet something in my mind
was just telling me I want to like I
feel there's more out of my business I
feel like I feel like I could turn this
thing around I feel like it can become
something great I feel like I really
felt like I would regret it for the rest
of my life if I didn't at least try yeah
I didn't want to leave it in the
situation where was just struggling to
get by and I would
Brett that I didn't give it my best and
I had a really hard time with it I
struggled and and I making that decision
of what camp to go with and what I
finally came down to was it's you know
I'm gonna I'm gonna take a year so my
friends were taking a year off out of
after graduating University explore the
world doing whatever and I thought you
know what those jobs may not be those
specific jobs the job opportunities will
still be available for me in a year if I
go trying something and come back but I
felt once I got on that corporate track
then be super hard to jump off it takes
a lot of guts and courage to leave a
corporate track once you're on and once
you start having family and other
commitments and I'm huge mortgage to pay
all that stress that's what gave me the
confidence to focus on my business I
said I'll do it for a year and it can
come back I can always go back and I
never went back and I think that was a
defining moment for me making that
decision that was a moment where I felt
like I am an entrepreneur and I'm so
glad that I took that path and and wish
I could say that I was simple of course
young entrepreneur just makes sense but
but I was scared I was nervous I didn't
know if it was the right thing to do I
lost sleep I was stressed out over it
but I listened to my heart instead of my
head in that moment and it paid off so
that was a moment that I decided to
become an entrepreneur thank you for the
question and let me share that with you
guys today if you guys like this video
please give it a thumbs up below I'd
love to hear your story how did you
decide to be an entrepreneur leave it in
the comments below or if you have a
question for me you can leave it below
make a video response and don't forget
to click on my face and subscribe to the
channel thank you guys so much and I'll
see you soon
you